AMONG THE DETAINED.
AND CANNABIS, HOW ENVIRONMENTAL
AND POLITICAL TURMOIL IS
IMPACTING ONE OF LEBANON'S
FARMING INDUSTRIES.
FIRST, POLISH OFFICIALS SAY IT
IS A POLITICAL PROCESS, NOT A
MIGRATION CRISIS.
BUT OTHERS ARE WARNING IT COULD
QUICKLY TURN INTO A MILITARY
ONE.
ESTONIA'S MINISTER SAYS IT IS
THE MOST VOLATILE SECURITY
CHALLENGE IN THE PAST 30 YEARS.
AS MANY AS 4,000 MIGRANTS FACING
DESPERATE CONDITIONS ARE PACKED
AGAINST THE BORDER ON THE
BELARUS SIDE TRYING TO CROSS
INTO POLAND.
GUARDS SAY ALMOST 600 ATTEMPTED
TO BREACH THE BORDER LAST NIGHT
AND THE E.U. BELIEVES MORE ARE
ON THE WAY.
THE E. YOU ACCUSES BELL RUSIAN
MIGRANTS OF PUSHING TO THE
BORDER.
>> THIS IS A CHALLENGE TO THE
WHOLE OF THE EUROPEAN UNION.
THIS IS NOT A MIGRATION CRISIS.
THIS IS THE ATTEMPT OF A REGIME
TO TRY TO DESTABILIZE ITS
DEMOCRATIC NEIGHBORS.
THIS WILL NOT SUCCEED.
>> THE POLISH PRIME MINISTER
WENT EVEN FURTHER CALLING THE
ACTIONS STATE TERRORISM.
LOOK SHENKO DENIES ALL OF IT BUT
E. SXURKS POLISH OFFICIALS MET
TODAY TO MAP OUT NEW SANCTIONS
AGAINST BELARUS.
SOME MAY TARGET THE COUNTRY'S
AIRLINE WHICH IS SUSPECTED OF
SHUTTLING MIGRANTS FROM THE
MIDDLE EAST.
E.U. OFFICIALS SAY THEY PLAN TO
VISIT THE COUNTRIES TO TRY TO
PUT A STOP TO THAT BUT RUSSIA IS
FIRMLY BACKING BELARUS.
TWO NUCLEAR CAPABLE RUSSIAN
BOMBERS SIMILAR TO THESE THAT
YOU'RE SEEING FLEW OVER BELARUS
TODAY.
THE KREMLIN SAID IT WAS TO TEST
BELARUS'S DEFENSES BUT THE
WARNING TO THE WEST WAS
UNMISTAKABLE.
MIGRANTS MADE IT CAUSE ARE
TELLING HARROWING STORIES OF HOW
THEY SURVIVED AND HOW THE
BELARUSIAN SECURITY OFFICIALS
AFFECTED THEM.
THEY SAID THEY ALL BUT PUSHED
THE GROUP ACROSS THE BORDER.
>> WE HAVE 100, MAYBE 100 AND
MORE, GOING TO POLAND.
AND SAY GO TO POLAND.
>> THE BELARUS POLICE COME, THE
GUARDS COME, FOLLOWED US, AND
THEN LIKE THIS AND THE SOLDIER
JUST THIS SIDE.
HE KICK ME IN THE FACE WITH HIS
FOOT.
SO I PASSED OUT FOR ABOUT A
COUPLE MINUTES.
BROKE MY NOSE AND BROKE A BONE
IN HERE AND MY EYESSWOLLEN.
>> ALL OF THIS AFTER THE E.U.
SLAPPED POLAND A MILLION A DAY
FINE AS THEY FIGHT OVER
SOVEREIGNTY.
HOW IS THAT FIGURING INTO THE
CRISIS AT THE BORDER?
THE REPORTER HAS COVERED IT ALL
FOR US OVER THE LAST COUPLE
DAYS.
HE JOINS US FROM BERLIN.
FRED, FIRST AND FOREMOST, WHAT
ARE THE CHANCES THAT THIS HYBRID
WARFARE ESCALATES INTO MORE
CONVENTIONAL WARFARE?
>> HI THERE.
I DON'T THINK EITHER OF THE
SIDES REALLY WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT BOTH SIDES
HAVE SAID THAT THEY DON'T WANT
TO HAPPEN.
OF COURSE, THE THREAT IS
DEFINITELY THERE AND THE THREAT
IS CERTAINLY GROWING.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE TO
KEEP IN MIND IN THAT AREA, A
VERY CONCENTRATED AREA.
WHAT YOU HAVE IS THAT THE POLISH
SIDE PUT IN PLACE AROUND 9,500,
MAYBE NOW OVER 10,000 OF ITS OWN
SOLDIERS.
AND ON THE OTHER SIDE YOU HAVE A
LOT OF BELARUSIAN SOLDIERS
TALKED ABOUT AS WELL, THE VIDEO
SEEMED TO INDICATE THAT THE
BORDER GUARD OR SOLDIER WAS
FIRING A SHOT NEAR MIGRANTS.
NOW, VERY DIFFICULT TO
INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY THAT THE
SIDE SAID IT IS NOT NECESSARILY
TRUE.
BUT OF COURSE, IF YOU HAVE THOSE
KINDS OF FORCES SO CLOSE TO ONE
ANOTHER IN A VERY TENSE
SITUATION WITH OF COURSE ALL
THOSE MIGRANTS IN BETWEEN, IT IS
SOMETHING THAT COULD BECOME VERY
DANGEROUS.
THEN OF COURSE YOU HAVE THE
RHETORIC GOING ON.
WE'VE HEARD THE KREMLIN
ESSENTIALLY BLAMING THIS ON
POLAND AND THEN THE FLIGHTS BY
THE STRATEGIC BOMBERS.
THAT IN ITSELF, EVEN THOUGH
RUSSIAN SIDE SAID IT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE CRISIS.
THEY JUST WANTED TO TEST THE
BELARUSIAN AIR SYSTEMS.
THAT IN ITSELF SENDS A CLEAR
MESSAGE TO NATO.
AND ALL OF THAT MAKES FOR A
VOLATILE SITUATION.
IN THE END, AS WE'VE BEEN
SAYING, NEITHER OF THE SIDES
WANTS THERE TO ESCALATE BUT IT
IS A DANGEROUS SITUATION AS THE
E.U. HAS SAID AS WELL.
>> AND FRED, AS THIS DOES
ESCALATE RHETORICALLY SPEAKING
AT THE MOMENT, IT IS INTERESTING
TO SEE ALLIANCES SPRING INTO
SHARP RELIEF.
BECAUSE IN RECENT WEEKS AND
MONTHS, WE'VE SEEN THIS TENSION
BETWEEN POLAND AND THE EUROPEAN
UNION.
SPECIFICALLY OVER JOSTLING ABOUT
SOMPBLT OVER THE POLISH COURT
AND THE EUROPEAN COURT OF
JUSTICE.
SO WHAT IMPACT IS THAT HAVING ON
THESE CURRENT TENSIONS AND HOW
IT IS MANAGED?
>> OF COURSE, WE HAVE THE NEW
ABORTION LAW IN POLAND AS WELL
THAT HAS CAUSED A LOT OF
FRICTION WITH THE EUROPEAN UNION
AND IN POLAND AS WELL, AS WELL
AS THE WHOLE DEBATE.
AND THE VERDICT BY POLAND'S
CONSTITUTIONAL COURT AS TO
REGARDS EUROPEAN LAW TRUMPING
NATIONAL LAW.
ALL OF THAT REALLY MADE FOR A
VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION BETWEEN
POLAND AND THE EUROPEAN UNION.
AND IT REALLY SEEMS AS THOUGH
RIGHT NOW, THOSE ISSUES SEEM
SOMEWHAT DORMANT AS POLAND IS
DEALING WITH THIS CONFLICT.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
SEEING IS THAT UNTIL A IF YOU
DAYS AGO, THERE WAS A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF CRITICISM THAT CAME
FROM THE EUROPEAN UNION AS TO
THE WAY POLAND WAS HANDLING ALL
OF THAT.
SPECIFIC WILL YOU THAT THERE IS
AN EMERGENCY ZONE AROUND THE
BORDERS WHERE JOURNALISTS CAN'T
GET IN.
NGO'S CAN'T GET IN FOR A LONG
TIME.
EUROPEAN OFFICIALS CAN'T GET IN
EITHER.
IT SEEMS LIKE SINCE THAT
ESCALATED, SINCE THAT LARGE.
A MIGRANTS HAVE COME TO THE
BORDER, IT SEEMS LIKE THE
EUROPEAN UNION IS UNIFYING
BEHIND POLAND.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THOUGHT WAS VERY INTERESTING,
POLAND ON THE ONE HAND SAYING
THIS IS NOT A PLAYING RAGS
CRISIS.
BUT THEN THE HEAD OF THE
EUROPEAN UNION SAYING THE SAME
WORDS.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE EUROPEAN UNION
IS MAKING AN EFFORT TO SHOW THAT
IT IS NOT DIVIDED AND IT STANDS
BEHIND POLAND AND THAT SEEMS TO
BE THE CASE.
FOR A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME, IT
HAS REALLY UNIFIED THE COUNTRIES
WHERE YOU DO HAVE THE LARG